[Musique]
d'accord
maintenant, quand on regarde l'ampleur du
problème, c'est beaucoup plus important qu'une
épidémie, c'est une recrudescence, donc c'est
vraiment le deuxième plus grand
niveau intermédiaire d'infestation qui se propage
dans toute la région, du soudan
à la somalie en passant par le kenya
[Musique]
moi
[Musique] étrangère
donc
[Musique]
je pense que nous avons fait partie du
côté de l'enquête et du contrôle du
locus à partir de janvier de l'année dernière, vous
savez que notre approche a complètement
été modifiée par de bonnes données, des
données opportunes et des données précises
et vous savez avec ça certainement pour
le kenya et de cette façon nous avons arrêté
nous avons arrêté 80 de revenir dans le
panier rouge où l'année dernière nous étions
confrontés à une situation très différente
en 2020 environ 2,5 millions de personnes
à travers différents moyens de subsistance agriculteurs
agropasteurs  et les pâturages
ont été touchés maintenant entre décembre
et ce que nous prévoyons et anticipons
jusqu'à ce que
le long terme commence avril mai, nous
parlons d'environ 3,5 millions de personnes dans la
région qui seront touchées